wanted to shoot in Iran went to Warner
Brothers and they were like absolutely
no Iran so that you had to kind of
understand that I can't come tell the
studio bad guy story about how they said
no to Iran so I said okay well I'm gonna
go and I want to shoot plates and I'm
gonna do rooftop so I'm just go think of
a digital camera I gotta do research
I've never seen any of the stuff it's
really important to me to go to Iran so
I went to the State Department and they
were like well you could go to wrong
they said that I would go show up
somewhere I think it's surrounded by a
bunch of you know like mullahs and hats
and they would whip out cameras and take
pictures and it would become a thing of
like politicizing me and the movie and
Tehran ban loves this government and
then it would just mix up the movie too
much for me anyway so I said forget it
so what we ended up doing was going to
Turkey instead which had some similar
architecture a lot of torques we didn't
have any we didn't have any Persians
because all the all the persons were
afraid that their families would get
some sort of reprisal if they got
involved in an American movie so we
switched back because look at our luck
it turns out the greatest concentration
of Iranians outside of Iran is like Pico
and westwoods so he came back here and
it was like we couldn't get out of the
way of Iranians everybody spoke Persian
everybody was an actor everybody was
want to be in the movie and everyone
wants to direct it so we got like filled
the the the airport and with the North
Hills VA was our was our embassy and
stuff can I say by the way we love
shooting California more people to shoot
in California it's an incredible place
to work and yeah we had fun we did a
couple of days in DC where we got to go
to the real CIA which they hadn't let
any movie go there and forever because I
think of the quality of the script and
because of Tony Mendez who is such an
esteemed guy there so that was cool I
met David Petraeus you know what I mean
you like meet all these people in
Hollywood and it's cool and then you
meet the real David Petraeus
just think I'm not a man we kind of
started from the point of view that we
both sort of in our minds and hearts or
whatever knew the essence of what we
wanted to do right and then and once we
trust each other and understand our
intentions of telling the story then we
know that we're not going to try to
distort into some propagandistic or with
some political agenda or whatever you
know so so if there are you know there
are characters that are composites of
characters you know the Iranians for
example that we show are largely the
most extremist part of a really diverse
population you know you have a and
hopefully that's shown as well in the
film that this is a really diverse
complicated society but the people who
we we needed and who were most relevant
to the plight of the houseguests were
the kumite and the Revolutionary Guards
you know so there were times when we say
are we focusing too much on these sort
of wild-eyed extremists but in fact that
was you know we knew that we felt
comfortable in the way that we were
approaching the story and in our view of
geopolitics so we thought we can you
know we can we can pick and choose the
parts of an Iranian society that we show
and hopefully give at least a sense of a
more diverse place it was smart it was
provocative it was unusual people don't
make movies like this all the time I was
free to judge it because I just came
upon an out of nowhere you know and
there was this really adult a
complicated thoughtful funny studio 70s
movie the kind that I loved and I never
ever get to see anymore
you know to me you have two
responsibilities one is you have a
responsibility to adhere to the deep
core truth of the story to not betray
the essence of the story you're telling
it true it's just based on true events
it better damn well be based on true
events the other responsibility as a
director is to make the best movie you
can possibly make because if the movie
doesn't work then your true story is a
tree falling in the woods so you got to
make a movie that hooks the audience
that brings them with you that gets you
to care about each and every single one
of those people who's in hiding to care
about the guy who's putting his life on
the line to go find him the Canadians
who've been sheltering them and so you
use as Chris said devices at times to do
that and sometimes you find real stuff
we go wow this is amazing this is
perfect we're gonna put it right in the
movie and sometimes they wandered around
for three days and it's like let's just
get them to the
final destination you know but but for
me I was always trying to balance those
things but I relied also quite heavily
on Chris for his his expertise his
research his nuance you know I had never
had this kind of relationship as a
director with a writer where where the
writer was you know separate had written
the script gave it to me
I gave him notes we made the movie he
was my partner he was amazing we were
together the whole time
I suppose it seems like a normal thing
to some of you but it was a complete
complete novelty to me